i had uh research go back and see if
we've had two pick sixes by the same guy
in
less than four minutes miami's mike
kozlowski versus the jets in 1983
he returned two touchdowns two pick
sixes in a span of 61 seconds
61 seconds
two touchdowns
carson palmer joining us now uh
have you ever had multiple pick sixes in
a game
morning dan um first of all first off
six five two thirty eight as of this
morning
but i don't think i've had two i know
i've thrown one uh a handful of times in
games but two two makes you want to go
crawl up underneath that injury tent on
the sideline and hide
what's it like though when when you
throw it and you want to make the tackle
but you you probably know you shouldn't
make the tackle but what's that
mentality when you throw an interception
got to make the tackle i mean it it it
hurts when you throw a
a pick
obviously for your own fan base and
as a player and as a quarterback you're
worried about your teammates you're
worried about letting your team down
you're worried about
defensively statistics you know those
guys on on the other side of the ball
in your own locker room don't want to
give up points and those points go on
the defensive side of the ball and the
defensive head the defensive coordinator
stats so
as the quarterback you just feel bad
that you let your team down and you
gotta make that tackle and make up for
the bad play you made
can you help me understand the taunting
rule that i don't know where it came
from like who complained about it but
it's a big deal in trying to understand
these taunting penalties now of
what is celebration and what is taunting
yeah i mean it's
when the league decides to to start a
new rule and enforce a new rule like you
know a defenseless receiver or leading
with the crown of the helmet or hitting
a quarterback low
they come with a vengeance and they come
with force and as fans and as players
you know they end up they end up most
likely averaging themselves out as
frustrated as you get when you have a
big third down sack and your defense is
going off the field and that flag comes
out
you know it hurts when you think it's a
bad call if it's a late hit on the
quarterback or a personal foul but they
end up as the season continues to go on
typically averaging out and some of
those calls end up going your way and
you're not as mad then
but did you ever have one of those
moments where somebody taunted you or
you like what is over the line in
taunting in your opinion
well from the league stance now you
can't even really look at a player after
you make a good play in his direction
say anything or spin the football or
um you know you just can't do anything
and it's the same thing that we would go
through in in the team meeting rooms
after games when coach had put up
the personal fouls or whatever it was
from the week before
everybody gets pissed that they threw a
flag and it could have lost the game or
it could have changed the game but you
know at this point as a defender or an
offensive player when you make a great
play you just need to look up in the
stands and taunt the stands because as
soon as you turn to another player that
flag's coming out the rest of the season
okay explain this to me lamar jackson
has a touchdown where he does his
somersault into the end zone
now he's not taunting anybody but it
feels like he's taunting everybody on
that defense by doing a somersault
carson
i think if he would have gotten done
with the somersault jumped up and spun
the football in a defender's face or
said something to a defender they might
have thrown it but like i said i mean it
when the league decides to make a change
the league comes up with a new rule you
need to just ride that wave some of them
are going to go for you some are going
to go against you
lamar jackson i i wondered if baltimore
would just go empty backfield and let
him stand back there and either add
another lineman or another wide receiver
but
how difficult would that be to try to
stop him or maybe i should ask how
difficult would that be for baltimore to
have that kind of philosophy on offense
the problem the reason they can't
because they have 15 more games and and
they need they need lamar to stay
healthy and i mean i love watching the
guy play he's one of the most exciting
players in in the league right now
outside of kyler murray in my opinion
but you got 15 more games of lamar you
got to keep him healthy there's so much
he wants to do with the football he
wants to put a shoulder in defenders he
wants to run guys over but again you got
a lot of football left and they need him
on the field if he's not on the field
they're a completely different team
but do you want exciting you know kyla
murray is exciting lamar jackson's
excited um
mac jones is not exciting you know
there's certain guys by design um
exciting always feels like you're right
you're teetering on the edge of
something could be unbelievable but it
could be unbelievably bad as well
yeah and and when you think about the
best to ever play brady's as unexciting
as it gets and he's got a whole fist
full of super bowl rings so exciting
sales tickets exciting gets you monday
night football games if you're an owner
but at the end of the day consistency is
what you want and um you know brady's
been really you know the uh the epitome
of that it's not super fun to watch i'd
much rather sit around and you know
watch a kyler murray run around and make
plays but at the end of the day brady
gets it done time and time again but as
a quarterback when you would look at
game film did for the upcoming opponent
did you ever look at the opposing
quarterback
and help your defense in any way like
could you see things that could help
your defense would that that ever be
part of your role
no i mean at the nfl level
the defensive coaches are so good
they're seeing what probably your own
quarterback is seeing so you know when
you start studying for a sunday game on
monday or sunday night
you're so focused on what you're doing
on offense and so focused about the game
plan and the formations and all the
adjustments you have the line of
scrimmage you don't have the capacity or
the bandwidth to study also the opposing
team's quarterback so you know
quarterbacks are worried about
themselves and and perfecting their game
as much as they can we're talking to
carson palmer heisman trophy winner of
course uh spent 15 years in the nfl
you were part of uh hard knocks weren't
you was that 2015
uh no i i did hard knocks probably in
like 20
08 09 10 and then we did uh the amazon
series in 2015. but did all or nothing
did they spend a week with you on
just watching how you prep for a game
uh i did that with peter king peter king
did a deal where he came and stayed with
me in arizona and kind of walked him
through what it's like to play
quarterback in the nfl wait he stayed in
your house in arizona
no he was in arizona for the week he
came over to my house at night when i
was studying and we just kind of it was
really awkward i was sitting in my
office at night my kids were asleep my
wife was in bed and i was over in the
office you know sitting there studying
and i would kind of look out of the
corner of my eye and peter was sitting
on the couch just watching
it was really kind of
eerie but no that's called creeper
that's why he's the best of the best
he's willing to you know to sneak into
somebody's house at you know 11 o'clock
at night and watch him study and then he
was there first thing in the morning
jumped in my truck and rode to work with
me okay but what would i see if i
watched you study prep for an opponent
uh i think everybody's different i know
some guys like to kind of sit back you
know on a couch and take notes i always
had to be sitting at my desk and i had a
my computer connected to a tv on the
wall and i had my notebook out
it's just hours and hours and hours
everybody does a little bit different i
would start and just draw every possible
blitz that team had run in the last four
or five weeks
and then go through all the protections
we were using that week and make sure
all the protections matched up and find
the ones that don't match up
where where you don't have a way to pick
up a specific blitz on defense and
figure out how i was going to get into
the game and adjust that so i mean it's
just every guy's different everybody has
a different routine but a lot of it sits
sits at a desk with a computer and a tv
and a notebook drawing and and taking
mental notes and jotting down notes
how often would you design a play
never
well now i do all the time i'm coaching
seventh grade football in idaho so
i'm coming up with all kinds of stuff
now but i i play for some great ones i
mean bruce arians and on down the list
and
if i ever tried to walk into bruce's
offense and show him a play i would run
you would hear so many mf's get out of
my office that's my job what are you
doing so i i knew uh i knew my role i
stayed in my lane and i just tried to
execute the plays that the coaches drew
up
how can you
explain jameis winston that he giveth
and taketh away that that desire to
maybe not have that
whatever it is that says throw it away
like gunslinger brett favre could do it
but he also threw 300 interceptions in
his career
yeah i mean you know this is obviously a
huge year for jameis um
you know he's had some greatness like in
week one with the five touchdowns and um
we've seen some greatness of you know
from a handful of years he was in
in tampa but
um you know when it consistently shows
up in different offenses when you got
different jersey on a different helmet
at some point
you know you're running out of you're
running out of runway if it continues to
go i would i would uh i mean they're
only one in one but i wouldn't i
wouldn't be shocked if you saw
you know a little bit more of the dual
threat there in new orleans right now
with both quarterbacks getting more and
more action with some of the decisions
that he's been making as of lately if
usc asks your opinion
for the next head coach
i you know i don't have one guy on the
top of my list i i think there's a lot
of really good candidates i i just like
that we've got pole position you know we
we fired our coach first so we're
starting the process right now and
there's been years where
you know you see a team that waited a
little too long fired a coach
and that coach would actually have
rather gone to that place that
university or that that organization but
they had to take a job because somebody
fired somebody earlier and they started
that recruiting process the next head
coach so you know i i don't know who
it's going to be i don't know that mike
ball knows who it's going to be just yet
i just like that we're the first ones
out the gate every coach out there knows
that our job is open i would think it's
an attractive job for every other
college coach and just you know most nfl
guys so we've got pool position we've
got an opportunity to hire the best of
the best when uh when these guys come
available that atmosphere at penn state
this weekend against auburn that
whiteout was unbelievable
the the toughest environment you ever
played in was where
man
i loved going to baltimore watching that
game last night uh kansas city and
baltimore last night there's something
special about baltimore but what about
college did you have college
well i went to florida state as as a
freshman and peter warwick chris winky
national championship year and we got
absolutely drummed
but
that place
rocks when when florida state is good
there isn't a whole lot going on in
tallahassee everything that's happening
in tallahassee is in doug walker stadium
and and being in in that environment
you know with with the chant where the
whole oh
it is really really special and unique
do you understand now that when we watch
a game
we think it looks easy at times because
of the angle of the tv you know the
cameras when
like you watch it now and you're going
god guy's wide open how could he miss
him but when you were playing
you probably thought you guys don't
understand what it's like to to play
quarterback you know the crowd noise and
there's blitzing and
this is why fans think god how did you
miss that throw it looks easy
i know what an idiot that guy was wide
open
yeah
you know that that's what makes this
game so great is everybody can be a
coach everybody can be a monday morning
quarterback everybody thinks coulda
shoulda would have done this done that
um
and and to be honest there was multiple
times i'm watching film on monday i'm
like man i can't believe i missed that
easy throw and man i can't believe i he
caught that or i squeezed that in that
window
but that's why being a a college fan an
nfl fan is so great right now is we all
get to have an opinion we can go on
twitter we can blow somebody up we can
go to instagram all that
uh belichick was asked about if brady
thought brady could play till he's 50.
you know tom has talked about that i
don't know if he's serious about it but
belichick in in his belichickian way
said well if anybody can do it it's tom
could you be 50 years of age and play
that position
that's so old it's so so old
you know i i thought 44 was on you know
unachievable but i wouldn't put it past
him i mean it just comes down to at some
point
i know i know myself you know i've got
12 year old my oldest or 12 and
at some point man you right i missed the
first practice i missed their first game
i missed an entire their entire soccer
season or football season or whatever it
is at some point your kids really start
to grow up
you know it's different when they're
three four five years old but when your
kids go are going into their teenagers
and you're not going to practices and
you can't take them to school and you
start missing out on some of that you
know i think that's probably on his
radar right now
and six more years is just six more
years of missed opportunities because
because as we all know as parents the
kids are gone fast they're out of your
house fast and they're off to college or
whatever's next so at some point you
know i think brady's gonna have to make
that decision it's going to be more of a
family decision and less of a you know
can my body do this can my arms still
have that same zip and that same
velocity on the football i think it
comes down to him more of you know i
want to be around my kids before they
head off to college yeah you could
always do what i did and just you know
basically not see them for a few years
when i did second shift at espn it
worked out well for me i don't know how
my kids are but you know maybe that's
the best thing to do i got to do that
and didn't have any guilt there carson
exactly yeah but you know now you you're
a grown-up you know your parent coach
you're doing it all all the right
reasons there hey it's great to talk to
you again and uh we'll talk to you soon
thanks dan have a great day that's
carson palmer weekly appearance in the
nfl season brought to you by our partner
level select cbd looking for next relief
visit levelselectcbd.com